[Musique]
un autre on combat décisif paris bouchon
jacques chirac ce matin propose de
nouvelles solutions pour tenter
d'améliorer la circulation dans la
capitale
il faut savoir que chaque jour paris
absorbe 7 millions de voitures vous en
doutez bien c'est énorme
et parmi les idées proposées un
gigantesque souterrain car en surface
les solutions on les connaît déjà
interdiction de stationner ou alors
parcmètres partout en mini gun
les embarras de paris ne date pas d'hier
et déjà à l'époque des carrosses et des
charrettes walo ne vais pas manqué d'en
souligner les tracas la situation dans
le paris d'aujourd'hui est devenu
quasiment infernale autant d'ailleurs
ont stationné que pour circuler en
l'espace de dix ans le nombre des
bouchons été multipliée par quatre et la
ville n'est plus en mesure de digérer le
million et demi de véhicules qui tentent
de circuler chaque jour pour tenter
d'améliorer la situation un projet
gigantesque est actuellement à l'étude à
la mairie de paris
il s'agit ni plus ni moins que de créer
un réseau d'une cinquantaine de
kilomètres d'autoroute à travers le sous
sol de la ville c'est le tracé enfoncé
qui figurent sur cette carte
il consiste en gros en un axe est-ouest
1 avec desserte du centre opéra hôtel de
ville et dégagement vers le sud
si le projet est retenu il permettra be
cool man d'environ 4000 véhicules par
heure
mais il n'est pas sans inconvénients et
son coût énorme risque d'être son
principal handicap
alors en attendant et pour tenter de
parer au plus pressé
on prépare d'autres mesures
interdiction de stationner sur certains
grands axes extension du stationnement
payant et augmentation des tarifs de 6 à
8 wrangler et même différent autour de
l'étoile priorité aux autobus et
augmentation éventuelle du nombre des
taxis enfin suppression du stationnement
dans certaines rues et certains
quartiers qui pourraient utilement faire
l'objet d'un référendum municipal
je crois que cette technique doit être
développée sans pour autant bien sûr en
abuser et que ce sujet est suffisamment
important et mobilisateur pour justifier
sa musique
[Musique]